consider the overwhelming success of the
Patriot encounter the money raised by
rebel what will you be doing with the
contributions well that's great all
right so I've done a couple of things to
say about that so the first one is you
know I would say a number of people have
been attempted and not an overwhelming
number but a number of people have been
attempting to take me to task for the
fact that my patreon support has been
let's call it overwhelmingly successful
and and so I'll tell you how I formulate
my response to that the first is I'm
generating almost all of my content and
making it completely publicly accessible
so it's free right and and so that way
I'm bringing I think awareness of
psychological issues to a very large
number of people and so far at the
moment my view count on YouTube is up to
13 million and I did a little bit of
calculations last week to try to figure
out what the total view count was for
the cuts of my lectures that have been
appearing on YouTube and then the
political material as well and I think
it's upward of 50 million and so I'm
making psychological and political
content available to 50 million people
and so you know that seems like a
reasonable thing to do now people who
don't agree with what I'm saying might
differ but I think that could be
separated from the educational content
as well so and then with regards to the
patreon subscribers every single person
who's doing that is doing it entirely
voluntarily and I also set up that
patreon account long before any of this
political material emerged so and my
sense with the patreon viewers and you
guys can clue me in if I'm wrong about
this is that there's two things
happening as one is it enables people
who are not very happy about the current
political situation in the West to to to
contribute to something that might be at
least to some degree attempting to stem
the tide of such things as toxic
political correctness and second that it
enables people to support my endeavors
to bring general education to a wider
audience and that seems like a good deal
for everyone and you know you might say
well it's a particularly good deal for
me and
I'm certainly not complaining about
what's happening but I would also point
out that it hasn't exactly been a
straightforward thing and so so I guess
if anyone else wants to try it they're
more than welcome to now having said
that I would also say that the real
issue here and I think this is the fact
that this isn't self-evident is also a
commentary on the toxicity of our
culture at the moment is that it
actually isn't the issue the issue isn't
really how much money you have I think
that that's a resentful and and
relatively vicious way of judging
someone else I think the issue is what
you do with the money when you have it
and you know I'm not a particularly
hedonistic person and I'm not 25 years
old you know I'm 55 years old and I'm
going to be a grandfather in a couple of
months you know thank God for that
and what I want to do with that money is
to do the best things I can possibly
think of to do with it and one of the
things I'm thinking about I started this
biblical series and a lot of that's help
thankful thanks to you guys on patreon
because that enabled me to generate the
capital that was necessary to rip
thinner because for 12 lectures that was
a $60,000 investment about that
something like that and then another
$8,000 for that for the camera work and
that had to be basically dealt with
upfront so it was a reasonable financial
risk now I've been crazily fortunate in
that theater tickets have also sold out
so it looks like the biblical series
will pay for itself with some extra left
over and so you know I'm pretty happy
about that because that gives me some
more working capital and then you might
say well what am I going to do with the
capital well I'm going to continue doing
the sorts of things that I'm already
doing I want to do a series on 100
greatest books of the Western canon for
example I want to move genuine
humanities education out of the
universities where it isn't being taught
anyways as far as I can tell
online where people can access it freely
I'm talking to a wide variety of people
right now about trying to do that in a
more formal sense so that the
possibility for widespread university
education can be made universally
accessible and one of the things we're
trying to crack is the problem of how to
teach people to write because that's a
real troublesome thing and by the way
you know you guys if you go onto my
website Jordan Peterson common you go
into courses and you go into psychology
430 if you look carefully there you'll
see that there's an essay rubric the
teeth that tells people how to write and
actually that's become quite popular and
so if you're interested in how to learn
to write I've written something about
that already and we're going to make a
piece of software that's going to help
people learn to write and so I've got
plans for how to make writing education
broadly accessible to people so I would
like to make humanities education of the
highest order broadly accessible to
people and I also want to teach them how
to write and I'm going to try to crack
the online university accreditation
problem and so part of the money that or
a substantial proportion of the money
that is being donated to me let's say or
is being offered to me by my monthly
supporters so that's all of you people
is going to be going to projects exactly
like that and the reason for that is
that what the hell else would I do with
the money you know I mean to me money is
a tool it's not it's not the means
whereby you develop a luxurious
lifestyle and spend your time burning
yourself to have to death in the Sun and
the Caribbeans learning cocaine and
chasing hookers you know it's just
that's just not in the cards for me and
and so I want to devote it towards the
sorts of things that have already been
pursuing except on a broader scale and
so you know and I think of people like
Elon Musk too not that I'm comparing
myself to Elon Musk but I mean he has
plenty of money and I mean you really
somebody's got to have the damn money it
might as well be people who have the
kind of vision that people like he does
have because maybe they'll do something
good for the world I mean I hope is Giga
factories produce batteries like mad so
that we can start to make alternative
energy sources economically viable and
maybe reduce our dependence on oil and
maybe get ourselves out from underneath
the thumb of the Saudi Arabs that would
be a good thing so the monetary issue
it's quite interesting it's like it is
not that
have the money it's what you do with it
so anyways those are some of my plans
and that isn't all of them because I'm
going to come up with a bunch more plans
and I'm going to try to implement them
as rapidly as I possibly can
I've put my clinical practice on hiatus
for the next three months so that I have
a chance to think and I've requested
that the University advanced by
sabbatical by one year so I should have
about a year to think about what I
should be doing with YouTube and how I
can be promoting broad-scale public
education of the highest quality and
that's a really fun problem to solve and
the fact that I'm being supported by all
of you people on patreon makes the
probability develop - that I'll be able
to devote my time to that much higher so
so that's what I'm going to do with it
I'm going to do the best things I can
possibly think of to do with it and
hopefully that'll work and so far it
seems to be going well so yeah I mean
I've been taken aback quite a bit by the
I mean it's not surprising that you know
the people who've been trying to take me
down let's say or squawking and bitching
because I happen to be generating a
fairly reasonable income from this
although I don't think about it as an
income as I already said I think about
it as a as a toolkit for pursuing more
interesting things it's like if that's
the best they can do with regards to
continuing to tarnish my name well then
let them let them go right ahead about
that and I think the proof is in the
outcome and like the biblical series and
that's a direct consequence of the
patreon support that seems to be going
like mad I think you know about 500,000
people have watched the video so far
with another who knows tens of thousands
of people listening to the podcast
that's just a bloody miracle that that
many people would be interested in what
I consider the fundamental foundation
for any true humanities education so
great we'll build from there and so
that's that's what I'm going to do with
the money so if people don't like that
then they don't have to donate or they
don't have to subscribe it's hardly like
it's mandatory